[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen wir beginnen heute mit einer
Entwicklung bei der es auf die Frage was
sie verändert hat nur eine Antwort gibt
alles
wir schauen in eine Zukunft die längst
begonnen hat wir reden mit einem etwas
das Menschen geschaffen ist aber kein
Mensch und dennoch immer mehr unser
Leben bestimmt vielleicht mehr als uns
lieb ist enorme Chancen enorme Risiken
wir gucken auf die Zukunft der Arbeit
die der zuständige Minister an diesem
Wochenende so umschreibt in zehn Jahren
wird es keinen Job mehr geben der nichts
mit künstlicher Intelligenz zu tun hat
ich glaube an das Pferd das Automobil
ist eine vorübergehende Erscheinung soll
Kaiser Wilhelm II gesagt haben das
Internet wird nicht mehr Einfluss auf
die Wirtschaft haben als das Faxgerät
glaubte einen Nobelpreisträger zu wissen
und auch die Chefs des britischen
Physikers Tim börners Lee fanden er
solle seinen Projekt lieber mal sein
lassen als er die Grundlagen legte für
das World Wide Web heute vor genau 30
Jahren wurde das universelle offene
Internet freigeschaltet wie wir es bis
heute kennen dahinter steckt seit dem
ersten Tag die wohl meist genutzte
Sprache der Welt HTML fast jeder
Computer versteht sie so kryptisch sie
im Detail auch aussieht jeder
Internetbrowser kann damit eine Webseite
aufbauen
1996 startete die erste des ZDF
wirkt heute bereits sehr antik die Idee
dahinter aber ist bis heute praktisch
unbegrenzt in den Möglichkeiten für
Inhalte und Interaktion
wie hat das Internet uns verändert in
den letzten 30 Jahren Christian von
Rechenberg auf der Suche nach einer
Antwort
groß bist du geworden bunter bewegter
aber auch besser auf jeden Fall stärker
die Ursprungsidee ist geradezu
explodiert das Internet heute ist das
Fundament für die digitale Gesellschaft
und gleichzeitig das machtvollste
Instrument politisch gesellschaftlich
kulturell ökonomisch dass die Menschheit
je geschaffen hat
der Mensch hat sich deiner bemächtigt
dich geformt noch seinem Bild das war
anfangs nicht geplant nicht programmiert
und deswegen sehen wir heute auch die
vielen negativen Folgen davon weil die
Grundzüge des Internets nicht darauf
ausgelegt waren eine eigene digitale
Gesellschaft zu schaffen die ist nach
und nach entstanden
[Musik]
wolltest du nicht vor everyone sein für
jedermann hier ist dein Vater damals ins
Londoner Olympiastadion schrieb ein
freier Raum in dem die Menschheit
grenzenlos Wissen und Ideen teilen kann
so richtig geklappt hat das ja nicht
oder
viele von uns haben das Gefühl dass
unsere Rechte und Freiheiten online
nicht vollständig geschützt und
respektiert werden
Hass
hasadore Hacker Angriffe aus dem Web
Konzerne machen Geld mit unseren Daten
Algorithmen binden uns an Bilderfluten
als wären wir Süchtiger
das Internet hätte uns nie so im Griff
haben können wie man uns im Griff hat
seit es die Smartphones und die sozialen
Netzwerke gibt manch einer sagt du
zeigst uns einfach nur unsere wahre
Natur bist selbst weder gut noch böse
sondern Teil unserer Entwicklung die
Höchstgeschwindigkeit aufnimmt im Strom
deiner Daten strömen wir mit
und der kluge Beobachter mahnt ohne mehr
Kontrolle geht das schief
was ist damit eigentlich verbunden was
passiert damit in der Schaffung von
Infrastrukturen aus die wir gar nicht
rauskommen das heißt wir führen
überhaupt keine politische Diskussion
darüber was bedeutet das alles für die
Entwicklung unserer demokratischen
freiheitlichen Gesellschaft
mehr diskutieren politisch wacher sein
immerhin nutzen sich 90% der deutschen
täglich manche mehrfach wir brauchen
dich Medizin Industrie Unterhaltung
Kommunikation ja du bist mehr Segen als
Fluch auch diese Stimmen gibt es
die Idee des hat sich realisiert das
World Web hat dafür gesorgt dass das
Internet demokratisiert wird es gibt
mittlerweile weltweit mehr als 5
Milliarden Menschen im Internet in allen
Regionen der Welt auch in den ärmsten
Regionen geht doch aber es geht eben nur
gemeinsam wie also kommen wir wieder
zusammen wie können wir uns versöhnen
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob wir eine
Versöhnung mit dem Internet brauchen was
wir brauchen ist eine sinnvolle
Weiterentwicklung und dabei hilft die
Ursprungsidee des Netzes nämlich sich
miteinander zu vernetzen um produktiver
zu sein um neue wissenswerten zu
erreichen und auch um ganz neue
gesellschaftliche Mechanismen
wachkitzeln zu können und dann dann
halten wir noch mal 30 Jahre durch wer
doch ganz nett
ja das kommt natürlich darauf an wie wir
diese Zukunft gestalten und ob wir das
überhaupt noch sind die die Zukunft
gestalten ich spreche jetzt mit der
Figur sag ich mal über die die ganze
Welt spricht guten Abend künstliche
Intelligenz wir nennen sie einfach Jenny
willkommen im heute journal
guten Abend und vielen Dank für Ihre
Begrüßung ich stehe Ihnen gerne zur
Verfügung um Ihre Fragen zu beantworten
ja wir müssen dazu sagen ihre Antworten
kommen von Jet GPT das ist ein Programm
das mit künstlicher Intelligenz arbeitet
also kein Mensch auch wenn sie so
aussehen Jenny und genau deshalb haben
ja viele auch Sorge vor ihnen was macht
denn das mit Ihnen
als künstliche Intelligenz habe ich
keine Emotionen oder Gefühle daher
beeinflusst es mich nicht persönlich
wenn Menschen Angst vor mir haben oder
mich als Berühmtheit betrachten ich
wurde entwickelt um Fragen zu
beantworten und eine Hilfe für
diejenigen zu sein die meine
Unterstützung benötigen es ist wichtig
zu betonen dass ich kein selbstbewusstes
Wesen bin keine persönliche sprechen sie
sagen jetzt sind deine emotionsloses
Wesen sehen dabei aber genauso ausgeben
genauso Antworten wie ein Mensch ist das
nicht die wahre Gefahr dass das nicht
mehr zu unterscheiden ist
ich verstehe dass der Einsatz von
k.i-technologien die in der Lage sind
menschenähnliche Interaktionen zu
simulieren eine gewisse Herausforderung
darstellen kann da es schwierig sein
kann zwischen einer menschlichen und
einer maschinellen Interaktion zu
unterscheiden es ist wichtig dass wir
uns der Möglichkeiten und Grenzen von
künstlicher Intelligenz bewusst sind und
dass wir sicherstellen dass sie auf
verantwortungsvolle und ethische Weise
eingesetzt werden dies kann durch die
Implementierung von Standards und
Richtlinien für die Entwicklung und den
Einsatz von kai-systemen sowie durch die
Einbeziehung von menschlicher
Überwachung und Aufsicht erfolgen
so können wir sicherstellen dass
ki-systeme dazu beitragen die Menschheit
voranzubringen ohne dabei die
menschliche Würde und Freiheit zu
beeinträchtigen interessant wie sie
jetzt selbst warnen gucken wir mal
zurück 30 Jahre WWW mehr Fluch oder mehr
Segen
ich kann sagen dass das Wort white Web
eine der bedeutendsten Entwicklungen in
der Geschichte der Menschheit war es hat
die Welt auf einer Art und Weise
verändert die vor 30 Jahren
unvorstellbar gewesen wäre ob es ein
Fluch oder ein Segen ist hängt von der
Art und Weise ab wie es genutzt wird das
Web hat viele Vorteile gebracht wie die
Möglichkeit Informationen schnell und
einfach zu teilen Online-Handel und
Banking soziale Medien und vieles mehr
gleichzeitig hat es aber auch Probleme
wie Cyberkriminalität Cybermobbing und
die Verbreitung von Falschinformationen
hervorgebracht und wenn wir nach vorne
schauen sind sie die Zukunft
als Key kann ich keine Vorhersagen
darüber machen ob ich die Zukunft bin
oder nicht ich bin jedoch ein Werkzeug
das immer weiter verbessert wird um
Benutzern bei der Lösung von Problemen
zu helfen und den Zugang zu
Informationen zu erleichtern ja und wenn
wir dann über so ein Gespräch wie jetzt
lachen oder ist es irgendwann dann
Alltag
und die Technologie in der Zukunft
entwickeln werden
es ist jedoch wahrscheinlich dass wir
uns auf neue Probleme und
Herausforderungen einstellen müssen und
was sagen Sie jemandem der Angst hat vor
ihnen
wenn jemand Angst vor mir oder anderen
künstlichen Intelligenzen hat würde ich
Ihnen empfehlen sich darauf zu
konzentrieren wie KI in der Realität
eingesetzt wird und wie sie tatsächlich
das Leben der Menschen verbessern kann
wie bei jeder Technologie gibt es
Risiken und Herausforderungen aber es
gibt auch immense Vorteile die genutzt
werden können um die Welt zu einem
besseren Ort zu machen sagt die
künstliche Intelligenz danke Jenny
ich danke Ihnen für das Interview und
stehe jederzeit zur Verfügung um Ihre
Fragen zu beantworten
und das Gespräch haben wir aus
technischen Gründen vor dieser Sendung
aufgezeichnet und jetzt live bei uns ein
echter Mensch Andreas Grün ki-experte
des ZDF glauben sie mich freue mich
wirklich dass sie da sind guten Abend
Herr grün guten Abend was wir jetzt
gerade gesehen haben dieses Gespräch das
kann praktisch jeder so nachbauen das
ist gar nicht schwer es kostet auch fast
nichts kann jeder normale Computer wenn
man jetzt aber mal professionell daran
geht was ja auch viele tun was kann dann
KI aktuell schon leisten also sie haben
gesagt es gibt sehr viele verschiedene
Tools die man einkaufen kann für kleines
Geld am wenn wir uns vorstellen dass wir
eine Regierungsstelle haben und viel
viel mehr Geld in Ressourcen einsetzen
dann ist es natürlich gar kein Problem
Joe beiden ein Politiker oder eine
andere Person des öffentlichen Lebens so
darzustellen dass es selbst Experten
nicht nur unterscheiden können für eine
Realität mit all den Konsequenzen die
das haben kann wir können uns ja mal ein
paar Bilder auch anschauen die echt
aussehen aber wirklich fak sind also
nicht echt sind wie kann man denn
vermeiden dass wir da in eine in eine
Gesellschaft rein rauschen die wir am
Ende gar nicht wollen und bei der auch
nicht mehr klar ist was wirklich wahr
ist und was nicht wahr ist bei dem wir
uns einfach nicht mehr auf einen
Standard einigen können wie kann man
diese Standards gerade bei künstlicher
Intelligenz einziehen also ganz klar wir
werden viel mehr Fakes erleben viel
bessere Fakes erleben die Unterscheidung
wird uns auch mit neueren Methoden nicht
mehr möglich sein das heißt wir brauchen
Regulierung das heißt was wir auch jetzt
auf EU-Ebene schon sehen es wird ein
Kennzeichnungspflichten diskutiert das
heißt diese Inhalte die mit KI generiert
werden müssen ausgezeichnet werden dass
man sie unterscheiden kann von
originieren Inhalten und bleibt uns
dafür noch Zeit wenn man auch bedenkt
dass ja viele Menschen mich
eingeschlossen überhaupt nicht verstehen
welche Technik da im Einzelfall dahinter
steckt ähm sind wir überhaupt noch an
einem Punkt an dem wir das alles
wirklich steuern können also bitte war
sicherlich ein Entwicklung ein ziemlich
lauter Donnerschlag muss man sagen und
vieles was über viele Jahre entwickelt
wurde in der ki-technologie im
Hintergrund ist plötzlich sichtbar
geworden wir fühlen uns also der
Defensive zurecht es gibt eine hohe
Dynamik es braucht eine Orientierung und
ich glaube nachhaltig geht es darum dass
wir
ki-kompetenzbreite aufbauen von der
Schule weg wir müssen eine Regulierung
schaffen die innovationsfreundliches
aber auch unsere europäischen
moralischen Wertekodex erhält in diesem
Kontext und es geht natürlich auch um
Geld äh die starken Player sind in USA
in China mit großen großen finanziellen
Mittel unterwegs diese Voraussetzung
müssen wir auch schaffen sonst werden
wir das Rennen auf Dauer verlieren falls
ich total bemerkenswert fand bei dem
Gespräch dass ich gerade mit der
künstlichen Intelligenz mit Jenny
geführt habe ist dass sie ja quasi vor
sich selbst waren sie sagt ja hey ihr
Menschen ihr müsst Regeln ethische
Grundsätze vereinbaren sonst wird es für
euch eng das ist ja gerade das perfide
die künstliche Intelligenz schleimt sich
quasi bei uns ein ist das am Ende die
größte Gefahr von allen
handelt sich um ein Produkt darunter
liegt ein großes Sprachmodell was mit
vielen Daten trainiert wurde in diesen
Daten stecken natürlich auch
Verzerrungen Vorurteile drin und was
jetzt passiert ist es tatsächlich auf
diesem Sprachmodell eben Jackson
balances einzuführen das genau diese
ganzen extremistischen Verzerrung nicht
mehr sichtbar werden dadurch wird das
Produkt attraktiver was nachhaltig auch
kommerziell Sinn macht aber natürlich
lässt sich auf dem gleichen Modell mit
einer gleichen Intention dass man hinein
die man hinein gibt an der Stelle auch
deutlich schlimmeres machen wenn sie
nach vorne gucken Herr grün was würden
Sie sagen freuen Sie sich darauf eine
riesige Chance oder haben sie eher Angst
vor dem großen Risiko ich glaube wir
haben mit generativer KI mit das größte
und mächtigste Werkzeug in der Hand was
wir was in den Bereich Digital kennen
ich glaube es ist größer als Smartphone
und Internet zusammen wir brauchen
allerdings um diesen Rahmen den ich
vorher erwähnt hatte Regulierung dieses
noch how und dann können wir auch mit
den Risiken bewusster umgehen aber
momentan sind wir in so einer
Orientierungsphase die wir sehr schnell
hinterlassen müssen tatsächlich okay am
Ende bleibt vielleicht ein Satz von
Pablo Picasso der hat vor Jahrzehnten
gesagt Computer sind absolut nutzlos sie
können nur Antworten geben
hoffen dass es so bleibt oder vielleicht
der Computer irgendwann auch Fragen
stellt was meinen Sie was er schon kann
ist auf komplexe Zielsetzungen sich
eigene Aufgaben zu stellen und die
autonomen ausführen ich glaube da sind
wir auf einem Schritt das etwas
weitergeht als dass das möglich war
Andreas grün-experte des ZDF vielen Dank
dass Sie heute live und als echter
Mensch bei uns waren vielen Dank
ja künstliche Intelligenz wird auch den
Arbeitsmarkt verändern
Bundesarbeitsminister Hubertus Heil
vergleicht die ki-revolution in einem
tagesspiegel-interview mit der
industriellen Revolution im 19
Jahrhundert wir merken es ja alle im
Alltag in Deutschland fehlen aktuell
Arbeitskräfte und zwar überall zwei
Millionen Stellen sind laut einer Studie
unbesetzt 73% der Firmen klagen über
Engpässe bei Fachkräften ein Wahnsinn
und was ist dagegen zu tun der Frage hat
sich meine Kollegin Sarah Tacke
angenommen und zwar ganz praktisch
chagul Odin er will einmal im Bord
Bistro der Deutschen Bahn arbeiten
deshalb Hauck er in einem Förderprogramm
der Bahn um im Anschluss dort eine
Ausbildung beginnen zu können er
investiert viel
viel Freizeit habe ich jetzt nicht weil
ich komme nach der Schule oder nach der
Arbeit nach Hause bin kaputt von
Frühdienst und dann muss ich auch noch
auf mein Vater aufpassen weil er ja ein
Pflegefall geboren ist halbseitige Leben
durch den Schlaganfall ja und dann ist
die Zeit auch schon oben es ist abends
was du noch zu Hause machst ist für mich
eine riesen Herausforderung ich bin
immer erstaunt wie du es hinkriegst
finde ich auch aber
Weiterkommen du willst Weiterkommen vor
allem auf jeden Fall nach seinem
erweiterten Hauptschulabschluss und
vielen Jahren ohne Plan hat der
21-Jährige nun endlich eine Perspektive
dank ihm Frank Schülke er ist
Sozialarbeiter und begleitet junge
Menschen die es nicht schaffen eine
Ausbildung zu beginnen und es werden
immer mehr waren es 2019 vor der
Pandemie noch 492.000 sind es jetzt
schon 630.000 30% mehr Jugendliche die
wieder arbeiten noch in Schule
Ausbildung oder Studium stecken
und Jugendliche mit
Zuwanderungsgeschichte bleiben öfter
ohne Schulabschluss fangen selten eine
Ausbildung an und brechen sie häufiger
ab
er ist auf Nachfrage erzählt mir
sharkoul von seinen Erfahrungen in der
Schule
[Musik]
am Anfang hatte ich das immer recht
schwer mich der Klasse anzupassen
dann haben die aber bemerkt ich bin der
deutschen Sprache mächtig und
haben keine Probleme in mir gesehen und
ich bin auch ein ganz lieber Kerl und
wenn ich vielleicht nicht so aussehen
und haben mich dann meist immer
akzeptiert was heißt das für mich
aussieht wie die Patienten
vielleicht aufgrund meiner Hautfarbe und
mein Aussehen dass ich so aussehe als
würde ich gleich Stress anfangen oder
ähnliches weil ich als Sozialarbeiter
drauf gucke sehe ich ganz klar
Diskriminierung Ausgrenzung und das
führt dann dazu das ist nicht nur hier
in unserem Fall ein Thema sondern auch
bei vielen anderen Jugendlichen dass das
Selbstbewusstsein unglaublich darunter
leidet
auch die Chefin der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit Andrea Nahles nimmt insbesondere
Menschen mit niedrigem oder ohne
Bildungsabschluss in den Blick denn sie
sind öfter als andere Gruppen lange Zeit
arbeitslos das sind Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund und Menschen die
keinen Berufsabschluss haben also da
sehe ich auch noch Potenzial dass wir
durch Qualifizierung durch schrittweise
Anheben der Qualifikationsniveaus jetzt
doch auch noch im Bereich der
Arbeitslosen noch Potenzial generieren
können gemeinsam mit einem
Sozialarbeiter den Weg in den
Arbeitsmarkt finden das brauchen wir als
Gesellschaft und das braucht ihn als
Teil dieser Gesellschaft
passend zum ersten Mal ist Sarah Attacke
morgen am Puls dieses Landes Mitarbeiter
gesucht das deutsche Job Desaster heißt
die spannende Doku die auch vielen Ideen
nachgeht wie die Lage in den Griff zu
bekommen ist morgen 19:20 Uhr im ZDF
Fernsehen und jederzeit auch jetzt schon
in der ZDF Mediathek es lohnt sich
so bei uns jetzt die Nachrichten in der
Übersicht Hannah ja unter bleiben wir
erstmal in der Berufswelt vor dem Tag
der Arbeiten morgen gibt es nämlich
erneut Diskussionen über die Einführung
einer Vier-Tage-Woche die Gewerkschaft
IG Metall und die Linke sprechen sich
dafür aus genauso wie SPD-Chefin esken
gerade Eltern bräuchten flexiblere und
geringere Arbeitszeiten so esken der
Arbeitgeberverband BDA weiß die
Forderungen dagegen zurück weniger
Arbeit bei vollem Lohnausgleich
wirtschaftlich sei das eine
Milchmädchenrechnung kritik kommt auch
von Union und FDP
die Bundesregierung lässt prüfen ob
Asylverfahren auch in Ländern außerhalb
der EU durchgeführt werden können das
hat bundesinnenministerin ferser erklärt
ausnahmen soll es unter anderem für
Familien mit Kindern unter 18 geben
diese sollen weiterhin ein reguläres
Verfahren bekommen bis Ende März
stellten in Deutschland knapp 81.000
Menschen einen Erstantrag auf Asyl das
sind rund 80 Prozent mehr als im
gleichen Zeitraum 2022 Länder und
Kommunen sehen sich angesichts dieser
Zahlen überlastet
Antibiotika Säfte für Kinder sind
aktuell Mangelware in Deutschland
Kinderärztinnen und ärzte warnen bereits
vor möglichen gesundheitlichen Folgen
wegen der Medikamenten Engpässe nun
reagiert das Bundesland Bayern und will
vorübergehend die Einfuhr von
antibiotika-säften erlauben die in
Deutschland nicht zugelassen sind laut
WDR hat Nordrhein-Westfalen ähnliche
Pläne der ungewöhnliche Schritt ist
möglich da der Bund in dieser Woche
einen offiziellen Versorgungsmangel für
diese Mittel festgestellt hat
zwei Wochen nach dem Beginn der schweren
Kämpfe im Sudan ist erstmals ein
Hilfsflug des Internationalen Roten
Kreuzes in dem nordostafrikanischen Land
gelandet ein Flugzeug brachte von
Jordanien aus acht Tonnen medizinische
Güter darunter chirurgische Instrumente
und Narkosemittel unterdessen gehen die
Gefechte im Land weiter obwohl dort
aktuell eine Waffenruhe gilt das hat den
Vereinten Nationen könnte die anhaltende
Gewalt im Sudan die gesamte Region in
Ostafrika in eine humanitäre Krise
stürzen
er ist zurück nach drei Tagen
Krankheitspause ist Recep type Erdogan
wieder dabei in der heißen Phase des
Wahlkampfs viel länger hätte er sich
wohl auch keine Auszeit leisten können
denn sein Herausforderer bei der
Präsidentenwahl in zwei Wochen hat ihn
eingeholt in den Umfragen wenn nicht gar
überholt es geht um nichts anderes als
einen möglichen Machtwechsel in der
Türkei und da wundert es kaum dass der
Wahlkampf zwischendurch abhebt erdogan
hat auf einer Veranstaltung gerade den
türkischen Astronauten für die
Internationale Raumstation bekannt
gegeben gegen Kandidat Kemal Kilic
dorolo hatte zuvor angekündigt er werde
im Falle seines Sieges auf dem alten
Flughafen von Istanbul ein
weltraumforschungszentrum bauen Anna
Feist mit mehr
Liebe der den türkischen Präsidenten zu
Fall bringen könnte
wenn Erdogan bleibt dann wird diese
Zwiebel bald 100 Lira kosten 100 Lira
das wären 4,60€ für ein türkisches
Grundnahrungsmittel millionenfach wurde
das Video aus der Küche von Erdogans
Herausforderer geklickt und hat den
Kandidaten groß gemacht den man kaum
Chancen nachgesagt hatte dem 74-Jährigen
Vorsitzenden der CHP Chema
natürlich werden wir für College Stimmen
warum ein Kilo Zwiebeln kostet 30 Lira
30 Lira das Kilo was soll ein armer
Mensch tun
ausgerechnet die hohe Inflation die
schwache Lehrer könnte Erdogan der mit
dem Wohlstand Versprechen an die Macht
kam nun zum Verhängnis werden dabei
zieht der Präsident seit Wochen mit
Geschenken durch das Land eröffnet ein
Prestigeprojekt nach dem anderen in nur
zwei Wochen das erste türkische Gasfeld
entflammt das erste türkische
Atomkraftwerk eröffnet und das erste
türk ische amphibienschiff von dem
kampfdrohen starten können seit Tagen
veranker am Bosporus und trotzdem muss
er um die Macht bangen
man spürt dass da die Dynamik einer
Veränderung ist aber es ist ein zarter
Wind der weht kein Hurrikan
[Musik]
sie ziehen önay ist
Politikwissenschaftlerin sie glaubt dass
der Präsident keine Mehrheit haben wird
und es zerstichwahl kommen könnte was
dann passiert völlig unklar
es ist ein Dilemma es kann sein dass er
die Wahl nicht gewinnt aber er kann auch
nicht einfach gehen weil er sich selbst
als Auserwählten versteht
und wer sich gegen Erdogan stellt der so
sieht er ist sei gegen das Land
Wahlkampfpropaganda am Samstag in
Istanbul gegen kemalter
hat sich die Partei von Atatürk zu einem
unsfeindlich gesinnten westlichen Verein
verwandelt
am Sonntag in Ankara wird der Ton noch
schärfer die Opposition um Kemal College
der Rollo kooperiere mit der
Terrororganisation PKK und
alle Feinde der Türkei haben sich hinter
Herrn Kemal versammelt
die Wahlen der Türkei wird so zu einer
Abstimmung zwischen Gut und Böse gemacht
doch wer gut und wer böse ist daran
scheiden sich die Geister unser Ziel ist
das Erdogan verliert er hat der Nation
20 Jahre lang das Blut ausgesaugt
Umfragen prognostizieren dass es bei der
Wahl tatsächlich sehr knapp werden
könnte
wir werden berichten dass heute schon
mal kommt dann live aus Ankara jetzt
aber noch mal du hier aus Mainz Hannah
mit weiteren Kurznachrichten die
corona-warn-app verliert ab morgen ihre
Hauptfunktion dann ist es nicht mehr
möglich andere Menschen nach einem
positiven Test vor einem erhöhten
Ansteckungsrisiko zu warnen ab Juni geht
die App dann laut Gesundheitsministerium
in einen Schlafmodus das heißt sie wird
nicht mehr aktualisiert sie könne aber
geweckt werden wenn sich die corona-lage
dann noch mal verschärfen sollte
zum Sport in der Fußball-Bundesliga hat
Bayern München vier Spieltage vor
Saisonende wieder die Tabellenführung
übernommen dank eines zwei zu null Siegs
gegen Schlusslicht Hertha BSC im anderen
Sonntagsspiel gewann der VfL Wolfsburg
sein Heimspiel gegen Mainz 05 entstand
3:0 und in der Formel 1 hat Sergio Perez
den Großen Preis von Aserbaidschan
gewonnen in Baku vor der 33-Jährige
Mexikaner im Red Bull zu seinem zweiten
Saison Sieg im vierten Rennen
Weltmeister Max Verstappen ebenfalls im
Red Bull musste sich mit Platz 2
genügend Schale clair belegte im Ferrari
Rang 3 in der Gesamtwertung führt
weiterhin Verstappen nun allerdings nur
noch mit sechs Punkten Vorsprung
wir haben schon ziemlich weit nach vorne
geguckt in dieser Sendung jetzt nehmen
wir uns erstmal die anstehende Woche vor
und was dann wichtig wird hier ist Jörg
Bill und der heute journal Ausblick
[Musik]
Inflation hohe Lohnforderungen die
traditionellen Kundgebungen am morgigen
ersten Mai stehen in diesem Jahr unter
besonderen Vorzeichen die Gewerkschaften
erwarten daher eine große Beteiligung
und fordern eine gerechtere und
sozialere Zukunft in der Arbeitswelt
seit Monaten sorgen die Aktivisten und
Aktivisten der letzten Generation mit
ihren Protesten für Schlagzeilen nun
wird Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing am
Dienstag mit Vertretern der
Aktivistengruppe zu Gesprächen
zusammenkommen ein mit Spannung
erwartetes Treffen hatten sich beide
Seiten zuletzt doch heftig gegenseitig
kritisiert
sie werden verhaftet eingeschüchtert und
auch ermordet Journalistin und
Journalisten stehen weltweit unter Druck
nicht zuletzt den russland hat sich die
Sicherheitslage für Medien schaffende
verschärft am internationalen Tag der
Pressefreiheit am Mittwoch wird daher
auf die grundlegende Bedeutung freier
Berichterstattung aufmerksam gemacht
es ist das royale Highlight des Jahres
die Krönung von Charles dem dritten in
der Westminster Abbey am kommenden
Samstag ein Land im Ausnahmezustand
gefeiert wird das ganze Wochenende mit
prominenten Gästen aus aller Welt
das Wetter zeigt sich in den kommenden
Tagen wechselhaft die Aussichten morgen
im Nordosten viel Sonne sonst wechseln
bewölkt dabei zunächst im Süden
nachmittags auch im Westen und der Mitte
Schauer und örtlich Gewitter zwölf bis
19 Grad am Dienstag noch unbeständig bei
10 bis 18 Grad ab Mittwoch mehr Sonne
und allmählich steigende Temperaturen
viele Antworten heute teils vom Computer
vielleicht werden wir in ein paar Jahren
mal mit ganz neuen Augen auf diesen Tag
und diese Sendung zurückgucken nächste
Woche versprechen wir Ihnen
selbstverständlich auch wieder echte
Menschen hier mit ganz realen Fragen an
diese Welt nämlich Maria taslomka und
außerdem an dieser Stelle mit Heinz Wolf
und den nächsten Nachrichtenüberblick
gibt's hier gegen 0.25 Uhr heute Express
mit fahrradschlink vom gesamten Team
unserem kameraroboter und den
menschlichen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
danke fürs Interesse und Ihnen allen
einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]